Aujourd’hui
c’est le solstice d’été,
le jour le plus long de l’année
dans l’hémisphère Nord.
Ici, à quelques kilomètres de Paris,
le soleil aura donc brillé aujourd'hui
pendant un peu plus de 16 heures
avant de se coucher.
Alors que dans six mois...
au moment du solstice d’hiver,
la durée du jour n’excédera pas 8 heures et 15 mn.
Pas chaud hein...
Alors, pourquoi cette durée varie-t-elle autant?
C’est parce qu’au fil des mois,
la Terre ne présente pas le même visage au soleil.
Vous le savez, elle tourne autour de lui.
Une révolution en un peu plus de 365 jours.
Mais ce n'est pas tout.
La Terre toune aussi sur elle-même,
comme une toupie.
Un tout complet en 24 heures, mais autour d’un axe qui est incliné par rapport au plan de l’écliptique,
le plan dans lequel
la Terre se déplace autour du Soleil.
Cette inclinaison, d'un peu plus de 23 degrés
par rapport à la verticale, est déterminante.
Si l’axe de rotation de la Terre était
perpendiculaire au plan de l’écliptique, comme ici,
la durée du jour et de la nuit
seraient parfaitement égales,
où que ce soit sur Terre,
365 jours sur 365.
Autrement dit, quelle que soit la
position de la Terre par rapport au Soleil.
Mais ce n'est pas le cas !
À cause de cette inclinaison durant le
voyage de la Terre autour du Soleil,
les pôles sont plus ou moins
orientés vers le Soleil.
L’éclairage des hémisphères
varie donc d'une saison à l'autre.
Quand la Terre se trouve
dans cette position,
l’hémisphère Nord est
moins éclairé que l’hémisphère Sud,
les jours sont plus courts au Nord qu’au Sud.
C’est l’hiver sous nos latitudes.
Six mois plus tard c’est l’inverse, l’hémisphère Nord est
plus éclairé que l’hémisphère Sud.
En 2020, le 20 juin, étant le jour
où l’axe de rotation pointe le plus vers le Soleil,
c’est donc le jour le plus long.
Très concrètement, ce jour-là,
chaque point de l’hémisphère Nord
reste plus longtemps dans la lumière
que les autres jours.
Et c'est ainsi que les fleurs de mon
jardin peuvent profiter ce jour-là
de plus de 16 heures de lumière. Et les
abeilles aussi !
Visuellement, ce jour-là,
le Soleil monte très haut dans le ciel ,
un peu plus de 64 degrés par rapport à l’horizon
à l'endroit où je me trouve.
Alors qu'au solstice d'hiver,
il reste en dessous de 18 degrés.
Alors ces derniers jours, la marche pour atteindre
le point culminant a été toute petite.
Et ce sera exactement la même chose
dans les jours qui viennent
quand ils vont
commencer à diminuer.
Les paliers seront minuscules.
Vu du plancher des vaches,
on a l'impression pendant cette période
que le Soleil
ne bouge plus.
Enfin, que son point culminant
reste à la même hauteur
et c’est d’ailleurs le sens
du mot "solstice" :
"Sol" pour "soleil" et "stice" du latin "stare"
qui signifie "être immobile".
Il y a quand même quelque chose d'étrange. Avez-vous
gardé des agendas des années précédentes ?
L'année dernière, le solstice a eu lieu
le 21 juin et non le 20.
L'année prochaine, il aura
de nouveau lieu le 21.
En 2022, rebelote. En fait il faut attendre 2024
pour que le solstice se produise à nouveau le 20 juin.
Alors pourquoi ce décalage ?
Je l'ai dit un peu plus tôt, la Terre tourne autour du Soleil
en un peu plus de 365 jours :
365 jours, 5 heures,
48 minutes et 45 secondes.
L'année civile est donc
un peu plus courte que l'année tropique.
Pour rattraper ce retard, les maîtres du temps
rajoutent donc régulièrement
une journée supplémentaire au calendrier civil.
Une tous les quatre ans,
ce sont les fameuses années bisextiles.
Ces années-là, comme en 2020,
le solstice a lieu le 20 juin.
Seulement, ce rattrapage
n'est pas tout à fait suffisant
car la trajectoire de la
Terre autour du Soleil
n'est pas toujours exactement la même,
sans compter que l'inclinaison de l'axe de rotation
varie légèrement. Du coup le solstice d'été
peut aussi avoir lieu le 22 juin.
Comme ce fut le cas en 1975
et comme ce sera le cas en 2203.
C'est loin !
Ou plus rare encore : le 19.
Prochaine édition : 2488
2488 !? Est-ce que
cette capsule existera encore ?
Du coup, j'ai une bouffée de chaleur.
Pas vous ? Enfin ça c'est normal,
car le solstice marque aussi le début de l'été,
la saison la plus chaude dans les régions tempérées.
Et contrairement à une idée reçue,
ce n'est pas parce que la Terre est plus proche du Soleil.
Durant son trajet,
elle dessine une ellipse
et c'est même le moment
où elle en est le plus éloigné.
En fait, s'il fait plus chaud, c'est encore une fois
à cause de l'inclinaison de l'axe de rotation.
À cause de cette inclinaison, l'hiver,
l'Europe de l'Ouest se trouve à cette hauteur.
L'été, elle se trouve ici,
plus bas.
La quantité de lumière qui chauffe une zone
allant de l'Ecosse à l'Espagne en hiver
ne chauffe plus
que la France en été.
L'été, le rendement est donc meilleur.
Voilà pourquoi il fait plus chaud.
Je boirais bien
quelque chose moi.
Enfin ça, c'est autre histoire !
À la semaine prochaine et d'ici-là,
profitez bien de l'été !
Chaque point de l'hémisphère nord
reste plus longtemps dans la lumière (...)
Cette année le solstice d'é...
Au moment du solstice d'hiver (...)